coconut coconuts
[Music]
my friend sent me the song called
coconuts by kim petrus and actually i
was like i'm going to recreate that or
try to recreate that using
using coconuts this video is brought to
you by my good friends in epidemic sound
but more on them later firstly i'm going
to start off by recreating the bass line
which sounds something like this
[Music]
i'm going to create the different base
notes by breaking open five coconuts and
using these hair ties
[Music]
face
in order to minimize food wastage i'm
going to reuse all these coconut shells
to recreate different instrumentation so
yeah i felt like that was just a
necessary thing to say this t-shirt is
now full of coconut juice so
i'm just gonna change it quick
cool i like this shirt way better it's
way more coconut appropriate cool onto
percussion
coconut shaker
now i'm going to try and recreate these
chords with the sound of
coconuts
lastly for the vocal melody a simple
little flute thing
it's pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coconut
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yeah coconuts made with
coconuts thank you for watching this six
talents video this is the last video on
my channel for the year but there's a
lot more to come next year so don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on that thank you so much to all of
you that have supported me and supported
this channel i love you and uh hope you
have a fantastic christmas and new year
off to tell you more about epidemic
sound firstly if you didn't know before
epidemic sound is the greatest of all
time sound and music library on the
internet with something like over 35 000
tracks and 90 000 sound effects like the
sound of the goat you just heard i found
that on the epidemic sound library and
if i find a sound that i like but it's
not quite what i was looking for i can
click the find similar button which
allows me to find what sounds in the
same realm of what i was looking for
keep an eye on the space because
epidemic sound and i are working on
something really rad for next year i've
linked them below so go sign up today
and i promise you that your music and
sound game will just go
up and up back to the outro
other than that don't forget you're
awesome bruh and i'll see you next year
[Applause]
you